hey guys my name is Pascal palea I'm the
movie director of on the horizon and
today I'm gonna talk to you about my
process using the red dragon camera
under Aizen came from a very ambitious
vision the goal was to shoot something
around the world we shot in France and
Utah and it was no crew it was me my son
guy an assistant I wanted to break the
barriers about what can we do with
absolutely nothing and have a high
quality product so that's what I was
trying to accomplish and then the big
question was what camera can I use
because nowadays anything can be shot
with absolutely everything we can use a
high phone DSLR whatever so my big my
big concern was I don't want to mess it
up I want to make sure that I can go
quick I can shoot fast I can walk fast
that there's no big preparation I just
want to shoot and make sure that the big
quality is there so I was debating what
camera do I use so I've chosen and I was
debating for months to just trying to
find the best camera possible so Indian
I chose the red dragon was it the best
camera for the job yes and no yes
because first it was the price that's
what I wanted to accomplish first what
can I get with my budget for my feature
film because the whole thing was shot
with $85,000 so the K I didn't want to
spend too much money on the gear but at
the same time I wanted to make sure that
the quality was there so what I did is
that I was finding doing research to
make sure that the look that I wanted
was was possible so with the red dragon
the beauty of it is that first it was
the money I had an amazing sponsor in
Montreal call post-modern and they gave
me for a very cheap price they give me
the camera for the month it was a red
dragon 66k everything was shot in 6k but
finished in 4k and delivered in HD some
platforms 4k so after a lot of debate I
was doing the pros and con and that
camera allowed me to make sure first it
was a row so the beauty of Roe was that
I can shoot anywhere and if I mess it up
I can
in post because everything if you guys
sort of film it was all shut almost
outside natural location natural
lighting so I needed I needed the option
is to make sure that I can fix
everything in post I didn't want to be a
crutches but I want them to make sure
that it was I wanted to make sure that
at least it was a tool that I can lean
on if I need to so so yeah that camera
the image is absolutely stunning you you
cannot go wrong with that camera it's
one of the best in the world but the
other camera that I was debating was the
Sony because I know that everything was
about to shoot in low light so the the
Sony cannot be beat even the canons I
was doing I was debating do I go non raw
compressed footage something super small
compared to the red that I had to make
it as a DSLR a little bit so everything
was shot with one and oh my lance and
the batteries so it was it was almost 20
pounds total so after one month it's it
can be a kind of a burden compared to
small DSLR can shouldn't fastest way
easier so you need to be in shape that's
for sure
so Indiana I just wanted to make I think
the the raw aspect of it just one over
everything the funny thing is that I
never shot with the red camera like
never it was the first time on set that
I've used it I didn't know anything
about it I've read online check videos
on YouTube and I was just like let's go
jump because in the end I think it's
always kind of the same thing you just
you know you can have any kind of camera
at the N is you need to be great you
need to be able to get the image out of
any kind of camera the it's it's all
about yourself it's see you know that's
what for me it was important to research
the location that fit my style so for me
I love to shoot outside beautiful
location everything needs to be puppy
eye and that's that's what I love the
most
so I know with the red camera was able
to get amazing dynamic range the raw
footage after that when it's time to do
the color correction that I did with
postmodern again it was just amazing
with the quality that you were able to
achieve it was I thought it was kind of
good about grading but now I realized
that I suck when you
with professionally it changes
everything what make me go to the red
camera was price-wise it was the quality
and at the end it was just like
price-wise it's too good to say but in
the end be any kind of camera can do the
same thing I think yes maybe in the
color grading section you can see a big
difference because it's not wrong but uh
but yeah I wanted to make sure that this
film was the best that I can shoot and
if there's any kind of mistakes I can
and in the end I didn't do a lot of
mistakes I was super lucky about that
not a lot of problem and sometime near
the end I had probably with the sensor
for some reason it started to glitch
like crazy and it was like the last day
of my shoot after 23 1024 day the sensor
completely messed up so I was freaking
out like crazy so I had a camera and
backup just in case and it was a
Panasonic gh4 that I'm still using today
and it's a great camera but it's
completely in a whole different ballgame
compared to red I'm not a big fan it's
that it's great it does a beautiful 4k
images but there's a one or two scene in
the film that I'm using the GA the gh4
but I don't know just someone left use
that camera so and then the next thing
how was the suni was a big big big
factor that I wanted to go because of a
low light a lot of at least after the
film is shot in low light and I know
Reds kind of suck and look light but I
was super surprised of the quality that
you can achieve in low light there's a
big nightclub scene with there's lasers
and flashes of light and everything is
blue it came out beautifully of course I
had to tone it down with with the noise
reduction in a little bit but mostly
what you see in the film it's is the
quality itself a lot of people asking me
what type of lens that I've used for the
film and everything was shot what I
think is the best lens that you can have
I didn't knew I didn't use cine lens I
never use it with another world with
those kind of lenses but it was shot
with the Canon 24 to 105 l series I
think is the most versatile best lens
possible stable as I it's a lens that
has stabilization in it and I think it's
just
it's just a dream come true you don't
have to waste time to switch to because
just that it cuts the time of your
shooting just always to stop stop
production change the gear change the
lens do testing so at least for me when
I should I love to make it as a
documentary so I need to shoot fast I
need to zoom in you don't lose time you
play with the actors you try stuff and
just for example the scene that you're
seeing behind me it was just improv
let's go with it and we save at least
one hour just because I could walk away
with the actors and play with them and
just you go from 24 millimeters to a 105
it stabilized and I think it's still the
best lines for probably 10 years that
the only lens that I've worked with and
even in low-light at one point I use a
24 millimeter 1.4 because I needed a lot
of low-light but other than that
everything was shot with a 24 to 105 I
think is the best sense if you need one
lens this is done a lot of research was
planning to the film just location wise
because I wanted to make sure that each
shot each location was stunning was pure
breathtaking that looked different and
looked like film that's what the main
kind of the main thing to make sure that
everything is perfect so that after that
a camera can do its job and just capture
everything and the beauty with the red
dragon is that everything that you shoot
is just so stunning with the dynamic
range I think it's almost 17 with the
red dragon and you're just being able to
capture all those details on the clouds
and you just maintain all those
beautiful details that you sometime with
other cameras you can lose one detail
that I would say the big tip for how to
shoot with red that's what I've learned
and I've learned had a little bit too
late but I think it's just what you need
to do is that you make sure that the
exposure it's always at 800 you don't
you don't need to go back because it's
wrong you don't need to bring it to 250
or 400 whatever I would suggest you
expose everything at an 800 and you make
sure that your Instagram it's always in
the middle or just a little bit going to
the eye light because once you're in
that sweet spot then you can bring
everything down you can
- six hundred five hundred four hundred
whatever and you're gonna have the most
amazing details and you have options to
play with because if you start let's say
at eight hundred but you expose too low
then you're screwed because after that
you have to crank it and it's not gonna
be as great so make sure that 800 is so
you make sure that you always in your
middle of I of the Instagram are just a
little bit towards the eye light just
that little trick seriously it's gonna
save you so much work and you're gonna
have the best possible result before the
project I've asked other filmmakers what
was their experience with the red and a
lot of people were seeing the same thing
it sucks a little light it sucks in a
low light and like I said I think it was
pretty amazing what you can achieve in
low light again you need to make sure
that you find location that there's
lights as an NP and at least it can be
spotlight of the street it can be card
it can be anything but if you have some
kind of source around it get a good the
most important part of my decision to
choose the red Indian was raw it was the
amazing dynamic range and quality of the
images price-wise because I had a
sponsor so that made a huge huge
difference and then it was just the
overall quality for me it was kind of a
trip of what it is the feeling to work
with the red camera hours I'm gonna come
out is it gonna be beautiful is it gonna
be great and overall even if I had some
glitch with the sensor at the end it was
just an amazing blast and it's always
fun or just you you shoot some stuff you
think it's gonna be great but it's when
you start to do the color correction or
you see some professional to do that
with your footage and you see in a big
screen that's where it blows your - so
yeah just make sure that there's so many
camera right now that the do the job so
just pick what you feel is gonna help
you the most with the project because
any kind of quality any kind of camera
is gonna give you the best quality
possible so at the end is just make sure
that you're just at he's with the the
camera for me it was - like a DSLR so I
was super at ease of course it's heavy
but once you get the trick the hang of
it
you're gonna be fine and you're gonna be
able to set it out like I said one big
tip that I would suggest to people is
that make sure you work with someone who
knows exactly how to grade your images
that's day and night that's gonna kill
it or make your project I was so shocked
and surprised to see professional tweet
my images to do something completely
amazing and it's just a collaborating
effort that you see that you're in the
room and you see your images and then
you play with the colors you test on
stuff everything was done in resolve at
the past modern facility and but we
didn't do any kind of lot or stuff like
that it was just pure curve and tweak
and a little recipe that they were doing
but as you can see everything is super
puppy I love when it's blast so I make
sure that all my location represent my
cell that I was doing I didn't buy any
lens for this like everything was rented
up the the 24-105 I got that lens and
the buy the rest I rented it everywhere
but you can you can make an amazing film
and have if you have a connection to
please bring all those gears that's
where you can cut down if you have
sponsors if you have connection you
don't need a lot of stuff that's what
I've learned you don't need a for me all
my I've done I've been doing this for 10
years and I never really on gears it was
just the simplistic way I can shoot and
I think that's the premier please when
you shoot like a documentary light fast
quick that's where you can be way more
creative because the look is gonna be
great but then after that you have the
time to play with the actors to crew to
create something super amazing and but
once you have the location the world
that you want to create then you can
bring any kind of camera and you may
he's gonna make it pop that's for sure
the whole film was it is on Adobe
Premiere I thought that'd be the process
of just bringing all the red footage
into the Adobe with flawless list it was
just it was super easy to is as soon as
you put it in your dragging it to your
timeline it pops it's worth natively and
then after that you just start editing I
didn't do any kind of proxies I just did
the 6k footage right away and then at
the end if you have and I have the
latest mag brewer the iMac and it worked
perfectly so you don't need the biggest
7,000 10,000 computer because I did it
trust me I bought the $10,000 computer
and I sold it because I thought it was
pure crap and then I went back to iMac
and it worked flawlessly so just it'll
be premier was just the best friend of
red I think it just completely
complement each other perfectly the one
thing that was super surprised about is
that when you shoot with red the image
quality it's so filmic and that was
another big factor that I was debating
between the Sony f55 and the red dragon
I was testing but I was seeing footage
online and I love how clean and digital
it was from the sunni and it was a good
thing and a bad thing because i wanted
to have this kind of a film look and but
with the red I don't know it was just
there's just something so filming about
it that it's maybe a less clean or less
digital the Sony and I think that's a
good thing because you want to be I'm
not a purist that I want to do film and
stuff like that for me I love digital
but the sweet that problem I think is
just it's too video ish you know what I
mean
so with the red I think is just almost
look like filming us it's almost
identical I think so yeah but thank you
so this is my experience with the red
camera Iowa I recommend it to everyone I
just bought it so I think it's it's a
great camera I want to work with that
process that kind of a culture of red
and once you're of course there's gonna
be other camera that's gonna come out
that's probably gonna be freaking
amazing but in the end just take any
tool that you want just go out there
shoes find amazing location create great
character stories and go for it you know
don't depend on your gear we're sewing
mm almost 17 we're just talking about
your Evo gear but focus on the story
focus of the world that's the mood that
you want to create and that's way more
important than any kind of gear that you
can accomplish so find what you love
find a tool that really helps you to be
creative that inspires you because I've
experienced that there's some tools that
can kill your creativity
I think the gh4 the death for me I
didn't like at all that camera and I'm
selling it right now so but with the red
when I took it I wanted to create I
don't know there's just some kind of
energy something about camera that just
connect with you so once you find that
tool go outside have fun shoot do
whatever you want and just have fun guys
and just shoot the most amazing freakin
project thank you